the most important sales technique if
you want to learn new business for your
company is to have passion and
confidence hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and out of curiosity I
recently did a search looking for sales
techniques online and it's amazing to
see how many techniques there are how
many different names there are four
things from the puppy dog clothes to
pour on the honey to- we're selling
there's tons of different options out
there for you but none of them will work
if you don't passionately believe in
what you're doing and have the
confidence to know that your product or
service will genuinely help people and
that comes across when you're talking to
somebody if it sounds like you're
reading from a piece of paper or trying
to memorize something it's not going to
work if you don't passionately believe
in what you're doing did how can you
expect somebody else to believe in what
you're doing it can't sound like you're
just trying to memorize a script the way
to handle objections is not to hear what
people say and then find out on your
script where it is and give them the
right answer it's not so much about what
you say it's more how you say it Sam
Walton was a founder of Walmart used to
say that passion is like a fever if
you're passionate and if you're
confident then other people around you
will become passionate and confident
they'll catch it like a fever if I came
on this video and I said hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I help entrepreneurs and I
believe that passion is really important
when you're trying to you know sell
customers and you know bring on new
deals is that going to convince you
probably not you're going to shut up
YouTube video say this Evan Carmichael
guy doesn't know what he's talking about
and move on to somewhere else and that's
what's going to happen to you in your
sales pitch customers will leave you
they won't give you the opportunity
because it doesn't sound like you have
the confidence or passion in what you're
selling buying is an emotional decision
so you want to get them emotional you
want to get them to believe in what
you're saying
so think about your own pitch when you
introduce yourself to somebody how are
you saying it not so much what you're
saying but how are you saying how was
your delivery try to tap into something
deeply emotional and personal you
started your business for a reason right
it's not just to make a lot of money you
started your business because you have a
passion for what you're doing I hope you
do or you're in the wrong business
you've got to let that out we've got to
showcase that you've got to be master
class one of the best in the world at
what you do and you have to have the
confidence to know that you can help
people solve their problems I hope you
apply to your business good luck for
those of you watching if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes you want to do more for you and
if you have a comment about this video
or question for your business I'd love
to hear from you in the comments section
below thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode